o lado pessoal e quem fala andar que
sejam muito bem vindos a mais um vídeo e
os traduz de que kagame nerds foi
oposição disseram para eu jogar e
exposta em um jogo por sinal faz net
fred olhem pra aquela árvore só que o
cruzamento medo e bom da história é a
seguinte nós somos o game e mais não sei
é o documento em quatro maneiras de
entrar dentro do quarto é muito texto
aqui e não vou traduzir esta letra mas
basicamente eu disse nos que nós temos
que ficar atentos ao barulho do bug
médio que se mostra de onde é que vem e
cada noite que passa o bug vai ficar
mais silencioso e mais difícil que é
algo parecido com familiares é fredes né
só que eu não ficava mais chance ao seu
perfil era mais vezes estuprar um pouco
porque isto foi o herói dos porta janela
armário e ventilação estas são as quatro
formas de eu conseguir entrar dentro do
quarto por isso temos que ficar atentos
na hora que eu estou a dizer que nós
vamos ter várias instalações que nos
distraem porque as distrações também
pôde treinar as pessoas o que vai
dificultar o nosso silvino e nós temos
que ficar bem atento às coisas porque
senão as dificuldades com um igual a blá
blá blá blá e não quer saber porque está
muito está ai de quem é esta que está
muito ao time está muito alto só por ser
que algum susto buscar toda aqui meu ou
o meu quarto embaixo de um macaco é que
uma catana que é um jogo estou lembram
se meu deus
acreditamos na evolução é porque o game
é uma das quatro mulheres do game é por
ser a e musiquinhas bebê quando era bebé
tem um brinquedo que tocava isto meu é
por isso que eu sou maluco hoje em dia
mas pra lá vamos lá estou no quarto jazz
total um salto foco é macaca é saber
tudo aqui dentro
era um clique no mouse boa tanto
continuo não mas eu quero ver eu quero
ver o que se passa aqui dentro ao som da
jovem estava então vamos lá carregaram
não acontece nada
ai ai ai do fmi estava estamos na noite
de domingo 11
ai ai construir a rússia pagou calma
costa deixou o filho porque merda
vítimas são justamente porque por foi de
15 ou 20 a 12
foi só podem porque ela tá falar as
contas com deus quando esta cama quando
ai ai nem no que ela tá conta porque a
inter chegou com tudo mas por que então
que o game não tattoo buckman de novo se
gosta que ela né ainda que investir em
cima de mim né não confirme isto é o
movimento estava ali na porta mas sem
luz
ae e foi isto que era pedra dentro da
câmara meu deus meus filhos já não
estava está muito tempo eu já não joga
essas coisas eu tenho uma camada era
fixa em pilha aa lo alguém dá uma pilha
eu nunca vi um sapo agarrar uma lua
nunca aí vou eu janelo fora ai meu cool
muito o vidro a matar um sapo de fora
não né não vou sair daqui eu não vou ser
pelo menos aqui em baixar longe meu eu
vou tirar aqui o avião eu te traz com o
avião e depois o que era aquilo é que
era uma lula gigante o meu eu não
percebi eu fiquei sem luz não sei como é
que volta a ter luz meu gosto camané
aoki bateria
agora você ir porque o cala boca
ele abriu o portão e entrou aqui dentro
eu estava dentro do armário né o que eu
preciso encontrar dodói com uma coisa
que me ajuda eu não sei que eu tenho que
fazer agora aí à porta da cápsula e isso
banhos gado da área que está essa fala
muito bem agora anda lá ok só tranqüilo
aqui eu não sei se o objeto foi cama
não sei se o objetivo é iluminar gustavo
está muito alto
ó eu só percebi eu tenho que levantar a
luz para não se ir embora
o barco do oeste um burro dark como é
que eu não tinha percebido isto antes é
porque não houve as pessoas e explicar
entre os jogos né pergunta que estava
encantado de cantar e cantar da marca ai
ai ainda que está a pedra era preciso
preciso mais duas baterias da matriz não
a bateria estou lixado fofoca texto
bruno fez as suas distrações são as tais
está só vai embora é vai te embora filho
da mãe é só ficar à espera de lula e
apontar luz na copa da uefa que sai
agora tentou entrar pela janela tudo
mais confira entrar porque agora já
descobriu o troco vez tiago que aquilo é
um luxo que o game é destruir meu eu
sugiro o sovaco vai proceder às três da
manhã o o hoje ela faltou a equipe
estudou moda e agora vou lá para ganhar
mais filhos né exatamente toque anda
agora sai debaixo da cama onde ó meu
deus a sério esta 1 entre meu e não tem
mais filhos não vão entrar e eu estava
entrando e não tem pilhas assegurou
siddique
não sei mas eu já não têm pilhas meu eu
em você você e vou tentar marcar e logo
uma ventilação o que quer dizer que ou
está aqui dentro ou não sair o que são
quase 4 da manhã precisa apanhar mais
pilhas meu mas não apenas para
acompanhar
não há mais filhos do que ataque o
ataque uma campanha legal isso é bem já
tem um rock band of joy ganhou e bateu
na porta alguém fez qualquer coisa que
não sei que filmes no youtube do google
mesmo
calma eu já tenho minha filha toda por
isso agora é só me concentrar diz pra
que ela apareça eu tenho que ficar
atento à inflação porque ventilação já
está aberta
sai da porta sai da porta bicho do
demônio não olhe pra mim assim marcar
com um cisto foi até às três da manhã o
jato muito perto
ai meu deus mas não não não o bicho é
muito fácil como é que é possível eu só
vou embora não o op por lei é um palhaço
ainda que um painel centro também eu
acho que eu consiga ser mais duas vezes
de luz o que quer dizer que eu vou
conseguir passar esta noite o exportador
já tardia é isso poder a dia ou não
exportadores tanto fone eu possa atender
o telefone
a não ser para distrair pérez e para
distrair o que nem aí
calma calma calma calma no andaraí
- tentamos de hoje e nela não eu sabia
eu já tardia ou confie curso que eu acho
que sim o quanto ama ainda lá de
estranho ainda qualquer pessoal
finalmente eu percebi o quanto este jogo
não é eu não tinha percebido que os
lusos já estavam o game mas pronto
felizmente consegui passar esta noite e
é espera fazer isso não gostar do estilo
quiserem vir mais diga nos comentários e
de como também querem que os jogos têm
alguns riffs e agora fiquei com vontade
até pra que vocês tenham gostado já
sabem o quanto eu vou falar que purifica
e vai até a próxima